this is Daniel Rubicon in his studio in
Gothenburg for the past few years the 30
year old has been winning one
international award after another for
his lamp designs his work is shown in
Milan London and Paris unlike a lot of
other designers he focuses not so much
on the lamp but on the light the big
problem is that that they're not
actually about lights
you know most lamps are the depressed
photos he's taking with the light turned
off so it's just much more about the
sculptural part of it then actually
designing light three beckons great
passion is daylight he loves exploring
how light behaves in nature and how that
can be recreated he can even make a
windowless space look sunny like this
stairwell in Stockholm he worked on the
installation for two years and used six
and a half thousand LEDs what you see
here this light patches it's actually
not the Sun coming in is actually LEDs
behind the wall to make the illusion as
natural less as possible and as real as
possible it's important all these
details like yeah this edge here on the
sides have to be a little bit more
sharper than the top and bottom they
have to be more blurred so it's a lot of
testing to get this right the river can
grew up in Norway he was heavily
influenced by the light in Scandinavia
where it's sunny almost around the clock
in the summer and there's very little
daylight in winter
I think a lot of people are very
sensitive to light and I think that's
natural when you see how the weather is
and how you know it's three o'clock and
it's already starting to you know the
sunset already and I think that the lack
of light makes you refocus on the
positive things with it he's been
fascinated by this effect since his
childhood his bedroom at his parents
home in Oslo was his first research lab
so to speak when this small little room
is lit with natural light you just feel
like you're part of something greater
than the four walls of the room you know
then you turn on the light the room is
transformed into almost occupationally
buqun's natural light installations can
only be seen in galleries or at design
trade fairs his lamps are now being
mass-produced and sell for between 400
and 800 euros it sometimes takes several
years for he buckin to go from hatching
an idea to completing a lamp
he uses computer programs and a 3d
printer to develop prototypes
despite their technical sophistication
the forms of his designs are always
clear and simple I just do the things
that I would want for myself and I think
in that way IQ I can create things that
are very honest instead of me trying to
figure out what what you would like by
4:00 in the afternoon
ibaka no longer has any daylight for
working so he heads home to his little
daughter her name is salt Spanish for
son